I just transcription as well.
Great.
All right, so we've got vector
optimized, optimized vector move
algorithms.
This as a sheet of benchmark
results with it in Excel which
was very nice.
I'm not sharing this excel
window but.
The results shall.
Large improvements, which
doesn't surprise me.
Because the.
By large I mean.
I'm up to three orders of
magnitude.
So yeah, large.
That doesn't surprise me,
because if we look.
Umm, so we've got. Let's see
what do we have. We have changes
to the build to the read me
these aren't.
So as I just changing the
folder.
It doesn't seem necessary to me.
I think they might be
consistency improvements. If you
expand the context above. I
haven't looked at this PR in
detail, but I vaguely recall.
It's the little blue context
thing right below the down
Chevron.
Uh, OK, that's a lot of context.
While that extended the whole
thing, that's alright.
Yeah. You, you, you don't wanna
hit that one, but now you can't
undo it.
I.
This seems like.
The opposite of.
Maybe if you're doing.
Ohh.
Out.
Are they just changing the? Read
me to agree with what the Cmake
Yeah.
already does.
No, because this is.
Like you, you've spent. This is
just specifying the build
directory so.
And then should be able to. You
know, you should be able to do
whatever you want.
Yeah. At the very least, it
doesn't seem related to the
topic of the PR, and it should
probably be a separate change.
Let's see if there's a.
Let's see if uh.
It it does contain a consistency
improvement like I I think the
reason Misco might have noticed
this is when he was following
the instructions the the
instructions by themselves can't
even agree on where the output
directory is. Yeah there you go.
Uh, here we go.
Ohh OK.
Yeah.
OK. Yeah, that's fine then.
Umm. I mean, yeah, I I don't
care that much. And and because
you know it is unrelated but.
Uh, it's a response to another.
Uh, you know to something else.
Class so I don't wanna be like,
no, don't do that because it's.
That's, you know, it sucks to
have to ping pong around like
that, alright?
And we have.
I'm Charlie. Before you get too
far into the review. Umm.
It would you be comfortable with
the higher zoom? I'm just
worried about our viewers in the
recording.
Ohh yeah.
At low resolutions.
So this or can we do do the the
text separate from everything
else?
You can definitely crunch the
left pane down and you could use
unified context if you like
that.
I do like that.
It's the button to the left of
changes from all commits that
will crunch it to the left. And
yeah, there you go.
Yeah. So that helps. How is
that?
I think there should be a lot
more viewable. Thank you.
One more check.
Yeah. All right. So then we add
benchmarks, which are the tests.
Umm.
Add benchmark is under
benchmark. Yeah, this is a
little bit.
Of a deep, uh nesting, but we'll
see.
We'll come back to that, see if
there's any good reason for
that.
And then we have see.
Happy Benchmark Copy N benchmark
move, benchmark.
The changes to vector and
changes to X utility. These
appear to just be.
It adds a level of like it of
indentation. Keeping all this
stuff the same.
And then also adds a call to
copy VIBOL which is in vector.
Ah.
Yeah, and I guess.
Ohh.
This is an ADL call.
Yeah, this looks like an ADL
call to copy the bowl, which is
why it can be inside X utility.
Uh, without making a sad, but
also, that makes me sad.
Umm, it's not even a DL's, just
dependent. Even if it were
qualified it would still work.
Oh, sorry, two phase. Look up.
I'm, I'm.
No.
I'm I'm saying wrong things.
You're right.
Yeah, it's this is actual
utility which I don't believe.
Yeah it does.
Yeah, I I should totally doesn't
need vector.
So.
Yeah, this is a an. OK.
Well, but how would we even fix
this? We'd have to.
No.
It would need to be declared.
That's the the issue I guess. I
guess. Could you expand upon
what we're very quickly talking
about?
Yes. No.
OK. So yeah, what we have here
is called a copy Bible is not
qualified at all.
On and you know the parameters
are the iterators, and are are
all the iterators you passed
into the function, so it's
clearly dependent.
Uh.
Like those arguments, make the
call dependent on the types of
your template parameters,
because that's the types of.
The arguments. This means it's
an ADL call and it's a
dependent.
80 I'll call and that means that
you trigger look up.
Inside the instantiation context
of this template.
Umm, which is why this works at
all.
Because.
This is an ex utility and copy.
The Bible is defined up in
vector which is not included by
X utility.
And so.
Without this.
You would only work if you if
you included vector previously
to axe utility. As it is, it'll
work all the time because you
can only get.
It's difficult to get vector
bull iterators without having
access to vector bool.
And and it's looked up after you
know.
At, you know, at the point where
you call, just copy, uncheck.
Umm.
But yeah, that's kind of nasty.
And so STL suggestion is we
could declare it however.
I mean this is an inline
function.
Umm.
So that declaration I think is
undefined behavior.
No, it's OK to and this is not
actually marked, it's constexpr.
You can declare it.
And then later provided
definition and everything is OK
as long as it's defined by the
end of the TU. Even if you use
Yeah, but that's not.
it in a constexpr context, I
believe.
Yeah, but it's not always if
you.
Like what if you call?
Copy on when it on your own
container and you don't include
vector at all.
Then the if constexpr should not
activate and the branch should
be consider dead. So the whether
copy V Bulls ever actually
define should be moot. I'm like
95% sure that the Standardese
works there.
Yeah, that's right. It should
bind in nothing. It depends and
The other thing the the other
thing is.
Umm.
the definition context, and you
know it's never looked up at
parse time. So I'm sorry it
instantiation.
Yeah. Also, I mean, if we do
just declare it then.
So that's fine.
Umm.
I think it's a linker error in
the real world.
Yeah, but, but you can't ever
see it. Yeah, OK, that's fine.
But. But we have to declare it
inside this if context for.
Ranch, right.
No.
Excuse me, it could be declared
outside and should be. It should
just be declared top level, not
like within a function.
Because if you look at the
signature, the signature of it
I.
doesn't care about V iterators
at all. It's completely
unconstrained.
Yeah, but I think even even just
having the that declaration
appear if you didn't happen to
include vector and you're not
gonna hit this branch, is UB
technically.
I believe it's OK to declare a
constexpr function and then
Why?
never define it and never call
it.
Ah.
There, there should be no case
where providing a declaration
It'll work.
is.
Umm by itself ill formed.
Huh.
Because because in C plus the
declaration is telling the
compiler.
I'm gonna have this thing. I'm
not gonna tell you what it is
yet, but it's gonna be a name.
You. You get a notes, a class or
function or whatever. There's no
actual like semantic checks or
anything until you actually
provide a definition. It's
always OK to just clear stuff.
Umm, I think it's.
I think technically just having
the declaration.
Is you be, but it's not.
Like it's not something that's
possible to check.
Umm.
And it works and I'll all the
compilers have the same
behavior. And if you do that.
Umm.
But anyway.
Ah.
It is very annoying that it.
Like if you somehow get those
vector bullet iterators then you
get like a call instruction like
it's an actual linker error.
That should be a.
Worse than that, it's not a
linker error, it's it might be a
linker error, but it might not
be depending on.
The order of your object files.
So.
Yeah, the way to fix this that I
would propose is declare copy V
bowl above, copy unchecked and
then that's it. Everything
works. You never get a linker
error. You never get a compiler
error if you call copy unchecked
with a non vectorable iterator
then the if context branch is
not selected and everything is
cool if you call it from with
the vector iterator then the
definition of copy V bowl will
be available by the time you
actually call the thing and then
everything works.
Yeah, no.
Yeah. So that's true. Like the
my concern is just that it could
be error prone in the future
because you then have that name
available.
Umm.
You know, throughout the rest of
the file, and if you happen to
call it in a place.
That could be reached without
having included vector.
Bad things happen.
In theory, yes, but in practice
copy V bowl is really only meant
for vector iterators every
single you should be guarded by
the sort of is VC iterator that
Misco is doing here.
It seems extremely difficult to
get into trouble.
Yeah, I yeah, I'm OK with just
declaring it up there, but I.
We could declare it in at
functions scope too.
I cannot think of any examples
in the STL where we have a
function local declaration of a
function.
Alright, if if there are no
other example.
If I'm wrong, we should not be
doing that. That's squirrelly.
It's not, it's a template, isn't
it?
We can't have a function. We
have a block level declaration
Yeah.
And as a template, yeah.
of a template, period.
No.
Yeah, that's a good point. I did
not remember that the template.
And you could ask him to stood,
qualify it, since we're trying
Yeah, well, yeah.
to do that with ugly names then.
And.
Yeah, sorry I didn't clearly
cannot pronounce under score
capital stood instead of colon,
colon, lowercase stood.
Thank you for getting it
correct.
Yeah. And then this all looks
identical, which is good.
Yeah. Great. OK. So that's just
modifying.
Yeah. And then this is the
actual test of.
The actual functional test, not
the benchmark.
Yeah.
Umm, so let's look at.
Vector.
Umm, so my understanding then is
that previously what was
happening was you would copy and
it would just go through the
fallback copy path and like.
Run all the iterator code
basically right like.
Do you references the iterator
and copies over 1 little bool at
a time?
Uh.
Resulting in you know lots of
ends in orders for for each
individual bit.
Hmm.
So instead what we want to do.
And I think it's.
My understanding is that that's
catastrophic for the processor,
right? Because every result
depends on the previous result,
so it can't really do any work
with instruction level
parallelism. And it's even worse
for performance than all the bit
OPS might suggest.
Yes.
Is that right? OK.
Yes, although.
Since we're doing all the
iterator stuff too.
It's possible. It's like doing a
bunch like it's doing.
Calls or something in between
2:00.
Especially in debug mode. But
yeah, it's not good, and even
even discounting that, like all
the bid OPS are just kind of.
Bad because like.
Though like.
In most cases, the resulting
word.
Like the end result that you
need is already in the source
vector.
And this just So what we're
gonna do here, my understanding
is we're figuring out where
like.
Which which chunk?
The beginning.
Of the range to copy is in.
And then we're figuring out
which bit is the start and then
we're.
Calling out that whole section,
copy it over, and then for any
full chunks we just.
Copy them directly.
And then at the end we figure
out where it ends. If we copy
just that portion.
OK so.
We unwrap.
The iterator.
You're a const cast. That's
weird.
I believe this is because if you
look at the definition of VCBE
iterator, it's the VB Const
iterator is the highest parent
and then the modifiable iterator
derives from it using the
constant one for storage. So my
putter is always a constar. I
That's so cursed.
think that's how it works.
Yeah, it's pretty cursed.
Is it always a rough winner?
That's.
This was.
This is one of the first things
that I fixed in vnext.
Uh, which is stranded in our TFs
branch, but they're the
iterators are templated in a
consciousness and we do not have
Yeah.
one inheriting from the other,
which is actually nonconformant
in some obscure situations.
Yeah, well.
Yeah, I'm. I'm OK with this.
With the contrast in this town
in this context, but let's just
keep that in mind and make sure
we're not writing to these
things.
Umm. First last destination.
Umm.
Oh oh, that that's a good point.
You you bring up an excellent
point. Why are VCBE first and
last modifiable? I mean, desk
has to be because we got a
scribble to it. But first and
last, we should never scribble
to those. Those should just be
Const.
Right.
That is a good point.
Let's.
I can't wait to write a comment
until we're through more of
this.
Because it might be, it might
end up being self-explanatory.
The end.
Let's see.
OK, yeah, this is just the end
of the destination range, which
is destination. Yeah, what's the
difference?
Uh.
Or source mask. I believe this
should be the.
But.
The mask for cutting bits out of
the end of the first word and at
least significant bits of the
first chunk.
I don't it does vector bool
store word by word or double or
or.
Or.
Like 8 or or bite by bite or
what?
It's an unsigned int. Units of
unsigned INT, under score V
base. I should say specifically
as an alias for unsigned INT.
Alright.
So these B based putters are.
Are pointers to unsigned ints
that happen to be the 32 bits
We'll say.
We'll say in.
sequence containing the begined.
I'm sorry, containing the one
that the iterators pointing at.
If I try and say double word by
double word I'm I'm knocking it.
Remember to say consistently.
Uh.
And word is ambiguous anyway.
OK, so this is all ones.
And as.
As an aside, Umm, we should,
although this is not the highest
priority, it's good to make sure
the code is kind of being
generic about what we base is
cause in the V next if we ever
want to make V base 64 bits on
64 bit platforms it would be
nice if as much code as possible
automatically worked, but it's
not critical right now.
Yeah, I think the the thing that
is not being generic about is if
we ever wanna make it smaller
than 32 bits.
This is not generic and I'm 100%
OK with that.
Umm, that's not worth it.
Umm.
OK, so all ones shifted.
Through the the offset.
Umm.
And for the destination, let's
see.
Want all ones?
OK. Yeah. So this is going to be
all ones.
Uh, yeah, so, so all ones in the
unoccupied.
Region.
Except reversed from what I
would expect.
The first, the first destination
mask.
Umm.
Is ones in the.
We'll say rightmost.
Places and the source is ones in
the left most places.
Umm.
Is is vectorable.
Oh, that might just be endian
this.
Umm. And then the.
Uh.
OK.
Yeah, technically it's not
processor endianness because at
no pointer reinspecting the byte
representation of the stuff, but
vector bool does have a
preference for least significant
or most significant where starts
filling from I always forget, so
I always have to look it up.
Pretty sure Miss goes got it
right here.
Yeah, I mean it's arbitrary.
You just have to be consistent.
OK, so single block source. So
that's just if we only have one.
Locke and we need to know that,
presumably because that means
that.
Are mask is double ended?
Uh, same with the desks.
The destination.
Umm.
I am surprised that we are.
Doing this instead of just
unwrapping it, but we'll see if
that comes up again. We might
just wanna unwrap it up here.
Like you know, do this task.
Umm.
You already excluded first
equals last.
Ohh, that's up here.
Uh, yeah, so this is if you're
copying 0 elements.
And so it's comparing both.
Which block you're on and what
the offsets are.
Umm, so this is when you're.
Copying more than zero elements.
Uh, last source mask.
On shift.
UM.
This is going to be 32,
presumably.
Minus whatever the offset is.
Umm.
And you're shifting OK.
UM.
And then we combine the masks.
Ohh.
Started the inverse of of of
what I was expecting. I zeros
are gonna be where we're copying
from, which is why this is
reversed from what I initially
expected.
Umm.
Or.
Yeah.
Umm, where is right shift set?
OK, that's if.
Huh.
Uh.
Ohh is right, shift is referring
to the direction of the copy,
not the direction of the bit
shifts.
I think.
Ohh, it ends up being
equivalent.
Umm.
Ah, OK yeah, this is just.
Now we shift by negative is is
my off unsigned.
Probably.
Uh, you cannot shift by
negative, it is undefined.
Uh.
So it's good that Minsky's being
very careful about that, just
like he's being careful about
doing a full shift, which is a
nonstandard.
OK. Yeah. So that's what this is
doing. This is just shifting by
the absolute value basically.
Of the difference between.
Yeah, but this is gonna so is
single block source.
So this is about the
destination.
But.
We don't know if the destination
is in the same block as the
source. Ohh but.
It could be arbitrary, so this
is like realigning the vectors
OK.
Yeah. So there's like 3.
Realigning things so that the
like.
So that the part you're copying
looks like it would if.
If the source and destination
had started out that had been at
the same offset.
Ohh, are you are you're bringing
up an interesting question. What
about?
Alias saying where they are
vectorable iterators into the
same container. Is any overlap
permitted because we're doing
something sneaky with the
processing word at a time.
There is the whole special case
about you can't have concurrent
accesses to separate elements of
vector, because they're not
really separate. I don't think
the plane algorithm has that, so
Well, I.
are we just subject to the usual
one way overlapping restriction
Yeah. However.
on?
However.
Ohh yeah, so if.
If it's subject to the usual one
way overlapping.
I think we're OK.
Because we're always reading in
full words.
And then writing in full words.
Oh, but if they all?
And yeah, and we preserve.
And I believe we preserve the.
Parts of written when we write,
we preserve the parts that are
outside the the copied range.
Are you right?
So you so you really do have to
have to be like strictly
overlapping in the way that's
not allowed.
Like in in the way that usually
cause that you know causes the
usual problems for.
Things to go badly.
Yeah. Yeah, I think you're right
that we're essentially we're
doing what the individual
operations would have done.
We're just doing it.
Up to 32 at a time. So and we're
careful to preserve the existing
data, so I don't think we should
stop over anything and therefore
we don't need extra aliases
checks because if we did, like
my brain would explode.
I think we're OK here.
Yeah.
But we should make sure that we
test that.
So his single block desk? That
means that.
We're in the same chunk.
Then.
Yeah, that's what this is doing.
So does mask is the the ones are
where we preserve data.
Oh no.
Well, uh.
Is this is gonna?
Wherever the.
I think you're right. The the
ones that were we preserve data.
Because the parenthesized left
hand.
Part of that expression says OK,
let's only preserve the bits of
ebbs that aren't being messed
with, and then after wiping out
to zeros all the stuff that we
want to overwrite, then we turn
on the source, fail.
Yeah, but we haven't. Let's see
where is source mask OHV for.
OK. Yeah. So we've already
zeroed out. So we've both up
here, we've zeroed out.
The the bits that we don't wanna
copy. And down here we have.
Umm.
Zeroed out the bits we do want
to copy, and then we ordered in.
That's fine, alright.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Than otherwise if.
Let's see single broadcast.
Otherwise you just do first ask
math that desk mask.
Uh, which is?
Year and.
Yeah.
Umm.
It's not completely clear to me
that.
Uh, we couldn't always compute,
you know.
That always doing this is so bad
it, but it avoids a data
dependency.
And I don't really mind it.
Umm. And I don't particularly
wanna play code golf with this.
Yeah. OK. Then we go on to the
next destination.
And last shift is.
Huh.
Ah.
I see. So this this is just
doing the other half of the copy
and.
Because.
Because we're in single block
source, that means that we can
at most like the the biggest
range that we could possibly
copy is 32, which can't possibly
span more than two blocks of the
destination.
And you can only be one break,
which is why they, which is why
we just did the beginning in the
end.
Directly here, OK.
It would be kind of nice to
unify the the the tail, the
processing of the tails.
In each case.
OK.
UM.
So this is just to keep it
constexpr in 20.
I hate this a lot, but we do it
in various other places and.
It's better than any other than
any alternative I can think of.
It's better than hiding in them
in a macro.
Umm.
Let's see.
Yeah. And that's just because we
need all this men move stuff.
We could potentially make it
always constexpr or.
I.
Writing out the men move loop
manually and hoping that the
optimizer can deal with it, but.
Whatever.
And then move exists because the
optimizer does not deal with it.
Well.
Yeah.
Uh.
So vbase 7.
Ah, that is.
Clever.
As hell.
So this is figuring out the
alignment of on a on a char by
char level.
Umm.
So that if.
The offset of your source range.
So that if the destination is at
multiple of.
Uh.
Is a multiple of 8 like.
Whereas.
Is multiples of eight past your
your.
Your source range.
In offset, then you can.
Uh, you can just use.
Ma'am, copy.
Let's say so.
Or offset times 7.
Yeah.
Why is this end end 7 instead of
a some mod operation?
It could be written as Mod 8.
I don't actually know why
certain is ampersand 7.
Umm, I mean, it's to make it.
An end instruction server mod.
I'm sure.
But.
I'm pretty I I would speculate
that the compilers people
optimization should be able to
do that.
Of course, in optimized mode, in
debug mode, you're right, it
would probably emit a modulo by
a constant.
Yeah.
It's kind of strange that we're
using ampersand here, but we're
I just didn't.
happy to divide by 8.
On 3790 through 3792.
Oh yeah, that's a good point,
that division.
It's like I'd expect to see and
in shift or mod and divide, but
the mixture is.
Yeah.
Peculiar.
Uh.
Not that I care a whole lot
either way.
It may be that the people
optimizer is not good enough.
Umm.
And give.
But we know we know it doesn't
run in debug mode so.
I might my recommend just
striking the second part of your
comment and just say like it
should just be shifts. Like if
we're gonna, we're gonna care
about debug code Gen. we should
just do the shift.
Don't we have president of doing
shifts elsewhere? Where did this
come up? Was it caricom? No, it
was something else.
We.
Not an issue actually for a long
time we were doing shifts
instead of divisions by two and
a lot of the algorithms because
the people optimize are broke in
the back end and we've had to
file an issue really filed the
issue prior to call precisely
Ohh yeah, in in our quick sorts
and stuff, you're right.
ticket at fixed yeah.
Yeah, I don't really. I didn't
actually know about the modulo
trick.
I'm sure I've learned the
whatever underlying theorem
makes that true at some point,
but.
Umm.
I guess I need to break out the
copy of hackers delight after
this.
Uh, But yeah, I like wish.
You mean replacing replacing mod
8 by Ann 7?
Yeah.
That that's like it. It's so
it's own decimal. Like if you go
Uh.
like Moda thousand, you'll just
keeping the last three digits.
So it's like ending with 999,
keeping only the last two digits
with bitwise it's easier.
No, that makes sense, yeah.
Umm.
Yeah, it's much harder to
explain the magic multiply
trick. I don't have a cute
analogy for that.
But the shift thing or or no.
Ohh no the.
No, no, no, that that, that's
where if you divide by something
that's not a power of two, you
can replace with the multiply
and a shift your magic.
Some cases. Yeah. Yeah, I I
think.
At least with shifts, it's like.
It's common enough that I.
And just write it out it it's a
little weird but and and if we
had a a, you know minus OG mode,
I would say just write the
division like it's fine but we
don't. So.
OK, so if.
In the in the code above, I
wanna ask something in the
middle line if you scroll up 1
bit.
Line 3791 how do we feel about
that, saying unaligned first
bits being used with dest? It
looks like a copy paste error.
It's not because 3787 just
proved that unaligned first bits
is equal to unaligned best bits,
but it seems very suspicious to.
Take advantage of that on line
3791.
I think it's, I mean this code
is inherently.
Like it requires that.
That they be aligned in the same
way for what it's about to do.
Oh, I I certainly don't dispute
the need for 3787. My question
is purely stylistic on 3791.
Should we say unaligned desk
bits so we match up exactly
Uh, yeah.
first? My off first bits desk,
my off desk bits last my off
last bits.
Umm.
Alright then, alright.
Yeah.
Because when I notice that I was
like, wait, is that wrong? Oh,
wait, it's right. But.
I mean debug performance is
probably better if you use like
for instance in both places.
Because if it's speculating.
I mean, you know, who knows? The
compiler might reorder this
stuff, but if it's speculating
through this if.
Uh, then it doesn't need to wait
for.
Both of them, like if we do it
this way then it needs to wait
for both of these instructions
to finish.
Uh, before I can do this before
I can do this line.
Umm.
I would be very surprised if
that turned up in profiling.
We're talking about, like
subnanosecond here.
Yeah.
This is true.
Uh.
But I I bet that's why I was
written now.
OK, so this is if we have any.
Any offset at all.
OK, we can we compute this
source and dest the source and
destination mask.
Uh, and we write B dest.
Yeah. And we write and they're
they're inverses of each other.
UM.
Actually.
OK. Yeah, they're strict
inverses of each other, but
we're going to compute them
separately because.
It's not clear that way and it's
better.
Ah.
UM.
And then we out what are these V
1st and VCBE? OK, yeah. These
are reinterpret casts.
Is a pointer cast through.
Char star.
Uh or two char star, which is
fine because it's char star.
Uh, I'm.
So that doesn't cause.
Fun aliasing problems, not that
it would actually, anyway.
Umm.
But.
Yeah, copy bits into, OK.
And the next to our alignment is
always the very next character
and then we.
VCBE last character.
I am concerned that we might be
copying additional bits here
that were uncopyable here.
Or yeah.
Oh no, but that would come up.
That would easily come up
because we would have just
overwritten them. So yeah,
that's fine. That would be
caught.
Umm is.
Is the strategy here right? A
partial byte? Do a block copy of
bytes in the middle and then
write a partial byte at the end,
in which case there should be no
overlapping.
Yeah.
OK.
I believe that is the strategy.
Umm yeah V desks Ch.
And yeah, copy unchecked returns
one after. I think the last
thing it wrote.
Yeah, and this is the same.
Is above.
And then we return.
The desk and that we computed
way up here.
UM.
OK. So is right shift where we
actually compute that?
Ohh OK.
So this is if.
I don't love the name of this is
Rachel. Very well, but.
Umm.
If the destination offset is
less than the source offset.
Do we need a carry?
Instead of just reversing the
order.
I think it's.
So this this is not, it's not
when the source and destination
are overlapping, but it's when
they occur at different
boundaries within the 32 bit
words.
When things are exactly lying,
things are awesome because you
can just directly copy the
unsigned ints over. But if you
No.
start at, say.
Umm.
You know why?
You should only need to do.
We should be able be able to get
aligned at some point, right,
and only have to do a partial
bit copy.
Yeah. So if we if we figure out.
The so this is for if the offset
you're copying into is less than
the offset you're copying from.
And if that's the case?
Ohh it's because.
Yeah, in, in, in.
Is because in this case you can
shift off the off the beginning.
And if you shift off the
beginning like.
So here you're going. OK how
many? You're gonna figure out
how many characters are copying?
You're gonna pull out that many
bits from first.
And end up with, you know, a
bunch of zeros and then those
bits and then maybe a bunch of
zeros, and then you're gonna
shift off.
Uh to align things.
Ah.
No, but that's your name. Even
that should not shift off the
front.
Well so. So basically there is
actually no, none, no, uh, no
one herent relationship between
the urns and the source and the
urns in the destination. Some of
the urns and the source will
need to be mixed across two of
the urns in the destination. So
that's the carry that miscoe
referring to. Essentially, when
we're doing this.
Transfer from the source to the
destination. We don't need to do
individual bit operations, but
we do need. We do need to do
some bitwise shifting and gluing
together of blocks to handle the
fact that not everything will
occur on Nice 32 bit boundaries.
Yeah.
But I still don't see how. How
like if you're copying
backwards, is what this case is.
I don't see how you can shift
off the front when you do that,
it's. You would need additional
bits.
Year ohh. Except then to handle
that you you reverse the order
in which you yeah OK.
But there is no copy backwards
here. This is copy forwards.
Said he always have the bits.
We're always incrementing the VB
first.
Yeah, so it's a but.
It's like a carry, as if you
were copying backwards, but you
do it by delaying by
incrementing VB desk.
Only sometimes.
Like V desk increments only
sometimes.
When you are.
Vtest may increment.
Multiple times before you
incrementally be first.
I do not believe that is the
case. On 3830, we get exactly 1
increment of VCBE DAST per
increment of VB first on 3826,
but we get an interesting
pattern here that does not
usually occur in such copy loops
on 3828 and on 3832 we have
multiple writes. So for every
loop on 3826 for the for the
main for loop where we're.
Yeah.
Gonna process a drev first. We
actually split that across 2
words of VB Dest, the 1st right,
then we advanced forward the
pointer and then the second
write, and then each individual
location in VB desk is written
to twice, once by the first half
the loop and once by the 2nd. So
that's where the blocks are sort
of getting fused together. But
there is aside from that odd
pattern, there's no irregularity
in.
How we're processing each
element is just instead of 1234
And you're right. I I think I'm,
I think I'm.
it's like 11223344.
I think I'm thinking of things
kind of backwards to how they
are.
In terms of like when you
encounter like the bits that you
need for that carry.
Umm, alright.
So source shift.
Is just the distance.
It is it is work, though I'm
not. I'm not sure if you're
aware, but just so the our
viewers are aware my off is not.
Umm if if I remember correctly
my office not an index within
the entire vector, it's a bit
index within the word. Is that
correct?
Yeah.
I think that's correct for the
vector bowl iterator, so my
Yeah, that's why.
office never. It's like 0 to 31.
If it isn't there a lot of the
stuff we've looked at is wrong.
Yeah, that's why this works.
Yeah.
That's why this works like.
Umm.
Like this covers both.
That's also why that assertion
about last stop my off being
zero and the a single block
source case was true.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, like, like, that's why
this cover is both like.
Copying from different size
vectors and the same you know.
The same sized ones at the same
position.
OK.
Umm.
So we write the first source
Val.
To the vector.
Uh.
Increment first our carry Val.
Is.
The next part.
That we need in dest.
And then we combine that and
write it to dest.
And then.
Ready for the next destination?
And we do this part again.
So I shift.
I guess because we're no longer
at the beginning, we don't need
to.
Yeah, we don't need to do this
masking anymore.
As we pull out a whole word
here.
And then pull out the other half
up here.
That's clever.
Umm.
View first what's VCBE last.
Uh.
Again, if we're overlapping.
Yes. So we didn't get a carry.
And in the destination we have
to do the same.
As before.
Same as.
Up here.
And in addition, we then have to
do the tail end.
Which doesn't need a carry.
Rise.
You just need to finish up.
OK, wait, what's this else
branch on?
OK, if if we're not a right
shift.
It should be basically the same.
Except we're keeping the use of
carry, Val and.
Of the carry in the non carry
parts consistent.
Which is why.
Some pictures would be good
here.
In the comments.
Which is why we shift.
And then.
Front all he needs to write
carry.
Is this cast of void needed?
That's a weird place to middle
warning.
I think Misco might have put it
there because it's needed in
generic code, but I think in
this case we're guaranteed to be
working with raw pointers to VL
base. I think that's the type of
VB 1st and vctest.
So you're right that the void
cache should be emitted.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess.
Yeah, I would have expected it
to be on DB first anyway.
Oh oh, that that's a stylistic
preference that we have. So it
Ohh avoid cast anywhere in
there. Avoid cast anywhere in
is correct that you can.
there. Silences the warning for
everybody.
It the the answer is yes. But
no, it depends on how many
operations you have. If you have
like plus plus X + + y + + Z
then you can put it on the 1st
and the 2nd but not on the 3rd.
That's too late. We can
eventually put it in the second
or in the middle because that
handles the most cases and it's
the most visually unambiguous.
If you said cast void Increment
VB first comma, increment V Dest
that does syntactically work. It
makes the left hand side of the
comma operator void.
But it looks weird because we
don't usually think of the void
cast as binding tightly, even
though in this case it does. If
you put in the middle, it works
because it makes the right hand
side of the comma operator void,
but it visually is unmistakable.
It's clear that we're casting
the right hand side to avoid
before doing anything.
Umm.
And the nice thing is if you put
it on the second one then that
also works when there's three
occurrences.
Umm it's it void defies the
right hand side of the first
comma operator and the left hand
side of the second comma
operator and I don't think we
ever have four in the STL.
OK so.
What cases are we going to have
to test? We're gonna have to
test.
Aligned.
One character.
On each character, we're going
to have to test single.
A single block source.
Uh, where the personal ascertain
the same block. Then we're gonna
have to test unaligned both
forward and backward.
Online by Char both forward and
backward.
No.
I don't like this.
Umm.
Oh, it's sort of random. OK,
that's better than if it was
just true, false, true, false,
true, false.
Uh.
I'll allow it.
For now.
Oh, and it's pretty existing.
Yeah, that's just moving that.
Moving this array.
Here.
We could probably constexpr, but
it doesn't really matter.
And only.
You can't have a top level
constexpr vector because the
allocation would survive.
Well, it could be an array.
But then it's not adaptable.
Yeah, it could be, yeah. Then we
would need to make a vector bowl
whenever we wanted to use it.
OK, test copy, no offset switch
length. Where do we?
This could be.
Why can't we just take a range
of the?
Ohh, because that would do a
copy. I see. Yeah, great.
And makes sense.
Uh.
We can't just copying.
His next really necessary here
I.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's not a big deal, it's just a
weird style.
OK, so this should be.
Totally aligned.
And we have.
That for that and.
Yeah, except we have caps on the
end.
And this should this should be a
single block.
There should be a full single
block.
Good.
OK, but this doesn't test.
On the tail, really.
You're copying into a tail, but
there's nothing there so.
Need to make sure that that
happens.
Happy Ann.
OK, this is identical though.
We're not really testing copy
and being.
Yeah, because it's copying into
the full length of the vector.
The destination vector.
Copy backward.
What?
Ohh, he goes right. Yeah.
Although presumably the point of
copy backward is to change the
rules about overlapping.
That's correct.
Yeah, OK. So we need to test
that.
And of course with copy forward
too, so offset in the source.
And then this. That weird. Yeah.
OK. So that's just because one
of these values is omitted.
Wait. False, true false for 67.
Should we not omit one and then?
Have the offset.
So I I I haven't thought about
in detail exactly what these
tests are doing.
But I am a little bit nervous
that we read through so many
special cases in the product
code and there's a lot of
special cases and there have to
be and it looks like they were
all diligently taken care of.
But when I see that many special
cases, then I sort of want to
see really exhaustive testing.
And So what I would have
expected to see here was
Yeah.
something that tests.
For every possible alignment
within a 32 bit value of the
source and for every possible
alignment within 32 of the
destination vector bool and for
a good mix of lengths to handle.
The special cases of single
block like exactly 2 blocks or a
bunch of blocks.
Umm test all that now the
problem is you do end up with
Yeah, well.
the multiplicative explosion,
but it's actually not that bad.
Like if you have 32 offsets
times 32 offsets times 32
possible links, that's only 32
Ki, just multiplied it out test
cases. And if we believe that
this should be fast now then
Yeah, I would prefer so I think.
could be doable.
I think the test is trying to
like. It's very in this way
because it wants to test vector
bool without like using vector
bool.
But I think it might be better
for the test to like implement
its own, like really brain dead
vector.
Well, the the we have such a
thing, it's called it's called
With iterators.
vector unsigned care. Like you
can take all the values that you
would put into a vector bool
instead put them into a vector
unsigned care and now you have a
reliable source of truth. You do
need to do comparisons you know
element wise, but that's what
stood equal will do anyways.
Yeah, the the reason I I could
understand like code not wanting
to do the full exhaustive
multiplication, but it seems
like there would be better ways
to do that like testing only.
Also we last code.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Basically what
that's doing, where it only
tests like certain lengths, but.
Yeah, this is not really
especially because I don't see
I'm worried it's.
any overlapping tests.
Yeah, no overlapping. And I what
I'm not seeing is exhaustive
testing of the possible offsets.
It looks like there might be
some there. I just I'm worried.
Uh, we we've been burned a few
times by algorithmic changes
Yeah, I I.
where we tested some stuff, but
we weren't really diligent about
it and we forgot. Oh, wait, what
if this source is like 33?
That's what I'm gonna say a
given like.
We can just talk test this
exhaustively. It's not a big
deal, right? Like we can.
Like we can do it.
Our strengths.
Huh.
Uh, for when you say overlapping
ranges, could you clarify that
you only want to test the ones
that are actually supported by
the standard?
Yes.
OK.
Ah.
That is to say, the.
Destinations before the source.
Or.
You're muted.
You're still muted.
Ah, sorry, I would say, uh, only
the ones that are permitted by
the standard, because the answer
is different for copy forward
versus copy backwards. So you
don't want to be too specific.
Sorry, I'm still figuring out
this mute button apparently.
Yeah.
Yeah. And then as a bonus.
I mean, you know.
Like if if we're using a, yeah.
Should you clarify what you mean
by using vector unsigned care
for this? I worry that.
What we're talking about might
not be captured here.
I think you mean like it's as
the reference, right?
Yeah.
Using vector as.
Hey.
Yeah, I.
Yeah, that's a good way to put
it.
I don't know if we need.
I think I'm less concerned about
random generation because that I
mean we we could always ask for
that, but that requires more
infrastructure and we we have
that elsewhere in the code base,
but.
In this case, we're not actually
that concerned about the data
dependency like as long as the
pattern of trues and falses is
Yeah.
kind of jumbled then.
And it as long as it's not so
repetitive.
I think it's the obvious way to
do it. It's the natural way to
do it anyway.
Yeah.
Because we really care about is
variation in the offsets and the
lengths and as long as the
pattern doesn't exactly overlap
them, we're fine with it.
Yeah. I mean, yeah, there's only
goes up to 67.
Let's just.
That's not too bad. It's like 2
words. It's not huge. It's like
2 words in a little bit. It does
seem kind of small.
But then you don't.
Yeah, but then you don't get 3
bytes.
Yeah.
We could be missing something
there. There is at least a
Uh.
little bit of attention around
3132, but what about 33?
What about all the offsets? I'm
just not seeing that I wanted to
see like 3 nested loops and
maybe some hackery to deal with.
It's taking too long.
But that would make me feel a
lot better.
And of course, the context here
that Charlie and I are well
aware of, but have not
explicitly stated as we just got
done dealing with fixing a bunch
of regressions caused by
performance optimizations and
those performance optimizations
were very good. I'm glad we took
them, but we got to be real
careful about breaking code that
works.
Umm at runtime because that's
always painful.
It's a good cause. These are all
runtime optimizations. That's
what's tricky with compile time
stuff. It's less risky because
if it doesn't compile OK, we can
fix that. It doesn't really ship
to users, but if it breaks it
runtime, it's always bad.
Yeah. Well, so for size, I mean
we wouldn't exhaustively test
with every size we would test.
You know.
We would take.
I I would say up up to some
limit. I'm honestly like 100 is
fine. Once we're once up to a.
Well, well, no, it won't, but
it.
But but it would have to be. You
know, we, we'd have to either go
by multiples of eight or 32.
Oh, no, no, that's that's scary.
Like you. Don't you specifically
Because if we're testing.
don't want multiples 8 cause
that that's gonna hide baldness
that occurs at.
You know non power of two
boundaries or something.
No, but.
The problem is that if we're.
Are you concerned about the
time?
Well, yeah, if we're testing
both if we're exhaustively
testing both the size and the
shift positions.
Yeah. Yeah. So, so there, there
we could we could like The thing
That's three things, right?
is once the test has been
written then it's easy to
selectively skip or end early or
something.
Umm, where we maybe go densely
like 12345. You know, up to
maybe 10 and then we start
skipping stump. But we still
make sure to test around, you
know the 3032 boundary and the
64 boundary and then throw in an
odd prime here. There once you
have the core loop written, it's
very easy to make faster. But I
think the focus should be first
on let's just test everything up
to the full you know 32 * 32 *
100. Just go nuts and then see
Yeah, but I think.
how fast it is.
But I think everything is like 3
to the.
200 something power.
No. So, so, so we're we're all
the possible variations. I was
just doing the math in my head,
there's what offset are we in
for the source? There's 32
possible bits. What offset are
we beginning at for the desk
again 32 and then how long is
the sequence that we're copying?
How many bits? So that's 32 * 32
times, say 100. That's not that
big.
OK, I was thinking I was
thinking the length, the number
of bits and then the beginning
iterator and the end iterator.
Which is much worse.
The length is the number of
bits, so so those are the same.
Yeah, yeah, but the the
beginning and ended rather is
different from the offset.
Umm.
Once you have the bit offset.
Of an iterator doesn't really
matter where in the vector bool
you are. You're right that it
is. It is a difference but.
The algorithm does not care
about words in the vector bool
that occur before the beginning
iterator. The vector could have
a 1032 bit words before that
initial iterator. We just don't
Yeah.
care about any of them.
So we really only care about the
offset where it is like the the
universe sort of begins and ends
at the VB 1st and VB last word
pointers.
Umm, so that's why I think only
the offset matter offset in the
length matters.
And what about the number of of
of bytes between them?
Umm, I think that's captured by
the number of bits being copied.
Those are the only three
parameters I can see that really
matter.
OK, so we'll say instead of bits
in the vector, we'll say number
of bits.
Yeah, being copied.
Yeah. OK, yeah, that's that's
fine. That's that's exhaust
exhaustively testable.
Yeah. And then if we find 32 *
32 * 100 is too slow, then we
can optimize it or run only the
fast matrix or something. We
we've dealt with this in like
the random generator tests where
those are a little hefty.
Umm or CARICOM, where we we did
end up randomizing it but.
No, but.
But 32 * 32 * 100 is is fine.
It's like.
Yeah, zero. That's zero. That's
nothing.
Yeah, it's, it's.
It's not like testing all 32 bit
floats.
Yeah.
And even yeah, like is.
It's fine now. It may be in
debug mode, yeah.
Let's see. Well, let, let's take
a quick look at the test.
And.
Oh yeah. The best horse. Yeah,
I'm the the fun secret about our
And the.
test is that they're all
compiled and non optimized mode.
I mean, we do vary between
release and debug and we
actually do not turn on
optimizations for the tests
except for the fast matrix.
Which is fine because usually
our code doesn't care.
Yeah, well, OK.
Interesting distribution.
Right. Yeah. So honestly, most
of the code to do all this stuff
already exists.
Like most of this exhaustive
testing code.
He thought his right here, like
you just need to.
Also do it the vector unsigned
int.
And do the comparison.
Umm.
Yeah.
And that's fine. I'm fine with
that.
We could just use well.
You know fine with that too.
As preexisting.
Let's make sure we're not
already doing what we want.
No.
Yeah, I think this is the first
time we really care about
boundaries. The count stuff
cared a little bit, but there's
just so many more cases here.
UM.
It's it's all the special casing
that all the if essentially the
nested ifs that we really want
like 100% code coverage
essentially.
Yeah, just wait until somebody
vectorizes this even more.
Well.
I guess doing that you just it's
just that inner memmove loop
which memmove will vectorize
anyway?
Yeah. So I think that's kind of
my feedback. I I don't think the
this is I I.
It's not hard to to write these
these exhaustive tests.
But the the actual
implementation looks.
It's fiddly, but it's fine.
And pictures would been nice.
I don't think the code is
relatively clear. It is the sort
of thing that benefits from
having a pad of scratch paper as
you work through each line.
I think with the test that we're
that would increase my
confidence and ohh before we get
to the end of our time slot, the
constness you said you're gonna
come back and comment on that
Yeah, the concepts.
later.
Yeah, I I don't see us writing
through like.
Yeah, well.
Yeah, like.
Well, we be dazed.
We.
Yeah, that desk of course needs
to be writable, but first and
last.
It might be worth mentioning in
this comment that this implies
cascading changes like with the
character pointers. Those should
also be Const.
I'll I'll just put another
comment.
OK.
He, he, he.
So yeah.
I'm sure whoever ends up better
than this, we'll figure out
without a comment here. When the
compiler rejects the reinterpret
cast that's casting awake.
Yeah, that that's a nice
advantage of the.
Forbidding of sea cast in our
code base C cast are just say
yeah whatever.
And yeah, Const char star can
can can alias in the same way as
Char star so.
That's fine.
Ohh would you need that boy cast
on the between the iterator
increments, by the way.
Oh, why?
Container iterators are
parameterized on pointer types.
Uh.
Ohh allocator.
Generally speaking on fancy
pointer types. In this case,
it's the allocator specifically,
but it must at least be on the
Ah.
They're not.
the pointer type of the
allocator which the user
controls. So these are hackable.
They're they're not.
Are there no hold on art? Can
you scroll up? Is VCBE first and
VB desk. Are those raw pointers?
I thought they were raw
pointers.
Oh, I'm sorry. Yes, these are
raw pointers. I'm not the vector
blurring writers anymore. I'm
wrong, yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, Casey's wrong.
Amazing.
I'm so happy to be wrong.
Yeah.
There's something that user
can't hijack in it's raw
pointers, yeah.
Yeah.
Raw pointers to actually no raw
pointers. General Fine, even if
Yes.
they are to user defined types.
Yeah.
I yeah, that I don't think we
need that.
Umm.
And if the compiler is
complaining about throwing those
values away, it's being bad and
you should feel bad because
like.
Oh, yeah, yeah, the compiler
would not complain about that.
That's the one. That's the one
reasonable place to put a comma
up, you know.
Yeah.
Yeah. OK. So other than the
testing changes, this looks
pretty in the Const stuff. This
looks pretty good and let's see,
we do, let's say we do call test
copy.
And it calls. Let's see.
Yeah, this is all.
Probably doesn't need to be in
the video review.
And it would be easier to do
with the editor split.
But.
Yeah, we're just at the end of
the time slot anyways.
Yeah, we are at the end of the
time slot as well. So I'm not
gonna go through and make sure
that every single test was
called and.
Stuff like that now. Plus I'm
known to forget that myself.
Umm.
Yeah, OK. Ohh I should.
Submit their view.
Before I forget.
All right. Thanks everybody.
Thank you, Charlie.
Uh.
Always fun.
And yeah, it's some pretty
substantial performance
improvements.
You know, stop the recording.